افدى مراسل الجزيره بسماع يدوي في جارين
قويين في مدينه اكرامات الشرقيه اوكرانيا
هياته والاركان قالت ان قوتها صدت 95
هجوما روسيا وذلك على محاور بخموت ولمان
في مقاطعات
في مقاطعه هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اكدت
ايضا ان القوات الروسيه الاكثر من 100 غره
وهجوم بصواريخها قصيره وبعيده المدى في
مختلف المحاور
اعلنت وحده كراكن الخاصه المقاتله في اطار
القوات الاوكرانيه في شمال شرقيه اوكرانيا
استهدافها برج المراقبه
المستقله المسمى غريمي غرينادر في منطقه
بريانيسكا الواقعه غربيه روسيا وذلك
باستخدام الطائرات المسيره في المقابل
اعلن حاكم
الروسيه اسقاط صواريخها في مدينه نوفي
اوسكولا المحاذيه لاوكرانيا
وزير الدفاع الروسي جو مدينه ماريوبال
الجنوب شرقيه اوكرانيا وذلك ضمن جوله
يتفقد خلالها المواقع العسكريه الروسيه في
اقليم دونيات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
الوزير تفقد اعمال اعاده البناء في
المدينه سير العمل في المباني والحياكلي
قيد الانشاء واضافت الوزاره ان استمع الى
تقرير حول شيء اكبر قناه مائيه تربط منطقه
الاوكرانيه
من دروس كوفكا جنوبيه كلمارت ينضم الي
مراسله جزيره حسن مسعود ومن موسكو مراسل
الجزيره ايمن الزبير مرحبا بكما لعلي يبدا
معك حسان وهذه التطورات المتلاحقه التي
تشهدها جبهات اوكرانيا عده ولعل الابرز
منذ اسابيع فعليا هو بخبط
بالفعل محمد باخمه هي قلب الصراع هنا في
منطقه دوناسك شرقيه اوكرانيا وفق اخر
تصريحات التي افاد بها المتحدث باسم اداره
عمليات الشرق الاوكراني هكذا وصف منطقه
باخموت التي ما زالت تدور فيها المعارك
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
التي تحاول الهجوم باتجاه هذه المدينه من
ثلاث اتجاهات مختلفه الا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تواصل التصدي لهاجمات متتاليه
باتجاه منطقه باخموت خلال اليوم الماضي
فقط تحدثت
القياده قياده عمليات الشرق عن صدها
لسبعين هجوما في تلك المنطقه في منطقه
باخموت لكنها تحدثت في ذات الوقت عن
الحاق خسائر بشريه كبيره تحدث المتحدث
باسم القياده عن اكثر من 250 قتيلا
جريحا من القوات الروسيه المهاجمه لمنطقه
واشار الى بعض المعلومات المهمه ايضا وهي
ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت قادره
واليوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى كما قال
بامداد
الذخائر والعتاد والمستلزمات الطبيه
للمقاتلين داخل مدينه باخموت وهذا يشير
الى ان الطريق الغربي المؤدي الى منطقه
باخموت التي كانت تحاول القوات الروسيه
قطعه عبر القصف وهو اكاد على ان الطريق
هذا طريق صعب وخطير الا انه اكد في ذات
الوقت على قدره القوات الاوكرانيه على
ايصال الذخائر ما يعني ان هناك امكانيه
القتال وفق قوله هذا هناك في بخ الا ان
التطورات لم لم تكن هناك فقط على عدد من
المحاور على عدد من الاتجاهات في منطقه
الشرق هناك في الديفكا في الديفكا في
لمن وكذلك في شختار ما زالت المحاولات
للتقدم والهجوم من قبل القوات الروسيه
متواصله فيما القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها
صددت 95 هجوما فئه هذه المحاور بالاضافه
الى محور كوبيانسك
جنوب شرقي مقاطعه خارجه كذلك هذا ميدانيا
وعلى الارض اما في الضربات الصاروخيه
فكذلك كانت الليله الماضيه دوت انفجاري
اداء انفجارات انفجرين او انفجارين هنا في
منطقه كراماتو تحديدا حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تعلن السلطات عن مكانها بشكل دقيق الا
انها كانت ناجمه عن صواريخ بعيده المدى او
اما الضربات الاخرى او المحاولات الهجوم
الجويه كانت على عدد من المقاطعات
الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن دينيبرو عن
ذابولوجيا وكذلك عن مقاطعه كييف حيث اعلنت
الادارات العسكريه هناك عن تصديها كانت
تتهج باتجاه هذه المقاطعات
ايمن الزبير ما الذي تقوله موسكو بشان هذه
التطورات التي سمعنا عنها وفقا لروايه
الاوكرانيه وخاصه ما الذي تقوله فيما
يتعلق بما اصبح كان المعركه تنتقل الى
داخل الاراضي الروسيه بعد ما حدث في كذلك
الحديث عن مدينه نوفا المحاذيه لاوكرانيا
قبل ساعات من الان
نعم كما اشرتم محمد تعرضت هذه المنطقه
مقاطعه للقصف بثلاثه صواريخ وفق حاكم هذه
المنطقه هذا الحادث الذي اسفر عن جرح
مواطن روسي لا يمكن اعتباره وصفه بالمفاجئ
لان هذه المنطقه منذ انطلاق ما تصفه روسيا
بالعمليه العسكريه تتعرض بين الفينه
والاخرى
للهجوم ولكن هذا الهجوم ايضا ياتي في سياق
ربما الاحتقان السائد في الحدود
الاوكرانيه الروسيه الشاسعه كما اشرتم
تعرضت منطقه او مقاطعه بريانسك لهجوم لافت
اسفر عن مقتل بعض المواطنين وبالتالي هناك
مطالب جاءت ايضا على لسان الرئيس الروسي
لتعزيز الحراسه وتكثيف الحراسه في الحدود
الروسيه
الاوكرانيه من جهه اخرى تستمر ايضا زياره
وزير الدفاع شويغو الى بعد عقد اجتماعات
مع قاده العمليه العسكريه توجه اليوم الى
ماريوبل للوقوف عند عمليه اعمار هذه
المدينه ومدها ايضا بالمياه اهداف وزير
الدفاع الروسي في اللحظه الحاليه هي تامين
الامدادات وايضا الوقوف على تدريب قوات
الاحتياط وايضا تامين النشر
الانتشار الامن للقوات الروسيه هذه هي
ابرز المواقف الروسيه اليوم السلطات كما
اشرتم تتحدث عن مواصله احكام السيطره في
مدينه باخموت ولكن كانت هناك التصريحات
المثيره للجدل لبريكوجن الذي تحدث عن نقص
في الذخائر وقال ان اي انسحاب روسي قد
يؤدي الى انهيار الجبهه محمد شكرا الزبير
من موسكو كما اشكر حسن مسعود الذي كان
معنا من دروسكوفكا جنوبيه